I have a comedy writer friend Tim Hobert
uh stand up to great great uh and um
whenever he's in a bad mood he does this
for by himself sometime even when he's
Alone
um if any woman
regardless of age as long as she's an
adult asks him anything
um he does a joke that he assumes that
they're hitting on him the you know
those little bars that separate your
groceries is an older lady behind us is
like oh I'm sorry could you hand me that
and he goes I am so flattered but I'm
married
and he'll say I gotta tell you I was
having a tough day
and
I was having a time you've brightened my
day I was having a tough day honestly
um but I am I am married I mean I wish I
was not I wish I was not but I am but
you made my day we're gonna make
somebody very very happy